good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday that
feels like a Friday because we have uh
no work tomorrow because the holiday
weekend uh Hey drugs how you doing I'm
darn good sitting with my green girl if
you're watching on YouTube Claudia and I
are in head to toe green if we were on a
green screen right now you would be
seeing nothing that where this show is
right now like 90 degrees oh my God
we're you know what we've gone green
quad Jackie Greta's influence we've gone
green Greta's influence cannot be under
overstated I think this is what she
meant when she asked us to go green we
heard her and we listened and so we've
gone green with our plastic cups and our
plastic straws cheers save the planet
how you doing it's I'm always asked I'm
always being asked how you learn I never
get to ask how you doing even though I
was the one who started
um I'm okay like I have been sitting
here with you for like 15 minutes and
you haven't mentioned my haircut because
it's not drastic I know but like it's
nice to know you know I spent the money
and the time at the salon it's nice to
be like hey great haircut I'm just so
used to you looking beautiful every day
that I kind of doesn't register for me I
don't know when you came in with a
haircut I was like oh my God I love your
haircut you're so gorgeous like you
should be on the cover of a magazine
like I was just kind of fawning over you
and it was just like kind of expecting
that sort of energy well one I saw your
haircut on Instagram last night so I
felt like caught up two it looks really
similar but three I will say it looks
like you got a really nice blowout
thanks I I didn't do anything drastic I
got like a quick trim you know I'm
losing my hair these days I can't be
affording to cut it all off you know
yeah that's so unlike you usually you
love to cut it all I know even though
the annoying thing is like when you need
your hair to grow like you have to cut
it it's just so counterintuitive no but
it makes sense yeah
girls with just like healthy locks okay
wait I just thought of something
you have like moments that are like so
inconsequential in your childhood I
thought of this yesterday now I just
thought of another one like random
moments in class that like were so
humiliating but like we're really like
nothing but you randomly remember them
yeah okay
I remember I was in two I remember I
remembered something yesterday that was
like so embarrassing that I did in
actual kindergarten but um like it was
so stupid and then I just thought of
another one when I was in the eighth
grade I don't remember it was like a a
Bible class like homage and she was
trying to make a metaphor about it how
in order for something to grow you need
to like cut it off or whatever I don't
remember what it was she was like so
when you guys need your hair to grow
what do you do and she called on me and
I didn't know at that time like in the
eighth grade like in order for your hair
to grow you need to cut it so I remember
answering I was like wash it
and it was just humiliating because then
like everybody shot up their hands they
were like cut it I was like okay I guess
we all just did a little Advanced like
this Cosmetology School how would you
know that thank you but but just
reminded me it's something I wanted to
tell you I remembered yesterday I don't
remember how or why this popped into my
memory but like the most humiliating
thing that happened to me in dead ass
kindergarten okay part of like the
kindergarten curriculum was every day
somebody would come up and like do the
calendar and like say what date it was
and I remember thinking like
how does everybody know the date like
it's such a like to me it was such a
far-off concept like month and day I'm
like how are we all knowing this like I
never paid attention I was just like
dreading the day I got called on and I
don't know if I knew that I was gonna
get called on that day or I just had a
feeling but I pretended to fall asleep
and she was like Claudia come to the
date
and I just didn't move and she like
literally came up and like was poking me
and I was like pretending I was
literally asleep even though any normal
human being who was asleep who would
have been woken up by like her screaming
in my ear
and I ended up doing it and like I If I
had paid attention I would have known
like she literally tells you like what
the month and the date is like you don't
have to come into class knowing the date
I just remember being so like confused
by the concept of the date I'm like how
is everybody knowing what month and date
it is it was and I was dreading like for
weeks like my day coming up and then I
just pretended to be dead in the back of
the classroom like but but I ended up
figuring it out it was humiliating I'm
so sorry you had to go through that yeah
I remember like I think I ate a bag of
Dipsy Doodles after I was like really
like that's what the emotional eating
began I understand I mean as a child
you're not really responsible for time
and like right days months now I guess
all kids know the date because they have
cell phones right but back then like
seriously how was anyone supposed to
know the date I mean I didn't even know
what dates were I guess there's always
like a calendar in the classroom but
still but if I'd paid attention I would
have known but I do think the point of
that exercise was to learn that's how
I'm sitting here today knowing I said
it's Thursday May 25th to learn about
them because you don't know them already
no I know it was a vicious cycle I I
understand so you have any stories like
that like trauma uh I'm sure that I do
they just like pop into my head at
random times and I actually suppress
them because they're humiliating yeah I
also have like stories like thoughts
that I've had where like I didn't raise
my hand in class where it's like I wish
I said that what do you wish you said
just like something stupid ones about in
too much class
umashi's like Torah like Bible yes
calling it Bible makes it feel Christian
but we have a Bible too but we call it
like the Torah homash yeah talmud yeah
so I just had like an interesting
thought that I feel like the class might
have liked but I wasn't brave enough it
was a thought
we're healing our inner child yes yes I
just shared mine come on okay okay so in
Exodus okay which book is that five when
the Jews are slaves in Egypt and Moses
brings them out okay what book is that
like three I feel like that's not the
end maybe four maybe four it doesn't
matter irrelevant no I'm just testing my
own objection relevance okay sorry sorry
so Moses like goes to pharaoh to to like
demand that he let my people go let
people go and like the first time he
goes in he says it like with a really
big boom in his voice and then he like
repeats it and it's like kind of lower
and it's the question the Bible doesn't
give like that much color to every
you're supposed to extrapolate like all
the rabbis they you know they spend
their whole lives like adding color to
the stories in the Bible and so the way
that like I saw it like kind of like in
a movie like I feel it's kind of weird
why would he say it twice like once loud
once quiet right so there's meaning
there that we're supposed to extract
right and that was the conversation we
were having in class like why say it one
sound one's quiet and I thought and I
feel like in the lines before it was
like he was galvanizing people to like
go with him to pharaoh to let his people
go and I feel like I could see it like
being in a movie where he like walks in
he has like all this like hype around
him he's like look at my people he's
feeling confident but then it's like
he didn't have as much fanfare behind
him as he thought and then he was like
let my people go
no that's totally the answer and you
should have said it okay well no it's
like we're all big and brave until like
we yeah you say it and then it like
Echoes and you're like oh [__] I thought
I had peeps behind right right but it's
just me so it's like let me go please
plz plz
interesting and so you never said it I
never said it but you knew it no that's
just like I don't know that I knew it
because it's all open to interpretation
into interpretation but like that was my
interpretation I feel like the class
might have benefited from it maybe even
the teacher like she could have been
teaching it maybe she'd never heard that
that theory before right and so maybe
like I'm I stifled like other years of
class learning yeah because they didn't
have yeah they didn't have that opinion
to ruminate on see and nobody in the
room at that time like thought twice
about you or like what you were gonna
say but that's like something that
sticks with you is it so weird
yeah everyone's on their own Journey
even though I'm telling you some kids in
my kindergarten class definitely
remember the girl who like pretended to
be dead in the back of the classroom no
because they don't really remember
kindergarten and again everyone's like
thinking about themselves yeah yeah like
so glad they weren't called on to do the
calendar yeah but what month was it
it was either March or may something
with an m i remember feeling like
triggered by the month because I
remember being a kid and I used to get
seasonal allergies so like when the
seasons were changing like I would have
to take Benadryl and I would hardcore
pass out in class but it was like so
acceptable yeah of course she has
allergies you're like the sick girl
she's down for the count her bedroom
kicked in right so maybe like they
thought you had taken a Benadryl yeah I
mean it was it was feeling unseasonably
warm if I remember correctly if it was
May you're kind of in the green zone
Green Green
um okay so that's today's unpacking of
childhood trauma tune in tomorrow for
more yeah you know we don't have a show
tomorrow I'll try and think of more
stories so this is the last show
everyone's gonna see me before I go to
tailored at MetLife and we have a bunch
of Taylor news because she dropped a
bombshell after the episode yesterday
yeah I wouldn't say it's a bombshell but
she dropped a nice outside the bombshell
a little surprise for the fans I watched
Keeping Up with the Kardashians season
one season three episode one
um last night was also Vanderpump Rules
reunion part one which we're going to
talk about in the TV recap segment I
know you didn't watch Kardashians so let
me just tell you like it was good I'm
excited it was nice to have the girl
he's back like there's definitely an
undercurrent Brewing between Courtney
and Chloe I mean excuse me Courtney and
Kim we know it's like about the Dolce
but there's just like a disconnect there
that we're seeing like Courtney was not
really in the episode that much
um but there's every time she's talking
about Kim like it's not good okay I'm
really excited to watch but it came out
at midnight and your girl was fast
asleep me too I watched it um this
morning while I was getting ready
because I'm in this like new era where
I'm watching things in the morning I
feel like it's such a great way to wake
up I watched more Ariana call her daddy
while I got ready this morning because I
can just stick my phone on my mirror
because I have this little sticky grippy
and I do my makeup in the mirror and I
watch like it's perfect so we're just
consuming content firing on all
cylinders consuming content creating
content yesterday we posted a patreon
episode
um kind of like the one everyone's been
waiting for about why I'm in New York
why I've been in New York and like why I
will be here for a little bit longer and
the whole story is on patreon I'm not
gonna tell the whole story again the
episode's 55 minutes it's like a six
weeks it's very detailed um but I will
share with the toast I'm not trying to
like click bait the news or anything and
like I feel like it's germane to if
you're a toaster and not a patreon
toaster like you still want to deserve
to know but I did have some pregnancy
complications that brought me to a
doctor in New York um to stitch up my
cervix and now I'll be getting my care
here for the rest of my pregnancy and
while the circumstances aren't great we
are just delighted to have you back
Jacks thanks it's been nice to be back
with my girl swirly I know she needed me
I desperately needed you and now I feel
like you're in a good place with your
maternity wardrobe you got a huge
package yesterday to the studio you're
currently wearing one of the pieces like
yes it feels like all's right yeah shout
out to smash and test because they have
like maternity jumpsuits and they sent
me a couple of them and that's really
what I'm feeling right now like you look
Fab I love a jumpsuit
but you the Kardashians episode opens up
with a Beyonce song which is like so big
budget of them and I've been singing it
all morning what do you hear me what
shouldn't you him happy like falling in
love it's a cuff it I'm in the mood to
[__] something up it's such a like real
line I am in the mood to [__] something
up maybe this episode maybe I'm gonna
[__] it up maybe not perhaps not know in
a good way no [__] it up it's like it
could be good okay oh I [__] that [__]
up like I tore it up you know or like
she [__] it up like she destroyed it I
wasn't I think yeah I wasn't saying the
light I was saying I'm gonna [__] this
up like let's [__] go [__] you know
let's give him the best damn episode
they've ever [__] seen okay it sounds
like you're saying a lot of conflicting
things but okay
just know it's all positive okay just
cool just a new pregnancy brain like I'm
gonna I'm gonna [__] it up in a good way
is that so derogatory when people say
that like it's okay when the you say it
says it so what I just did I was
acknowledging was not okay yeah Mama's
pregnancy brain Mama's getter The Mamas
came out in full force for yesterday I
was like scrolling through comments and
it was so great well not great but you
know what I mean what was so positive
about your episode was that when you
were dealing with this like weird kind
of medical Rarity that we didn't know
much about we didn't like have anyone we
could talk to who was like hey did you
have this like what did you do and
that's the beauty of the toast in like
such a great community of women but
especially moms was like so many people
were like oh my sister had this I had
this here's what happened to me and it's
just so much comforting that's you know
you're not like this freak like you had
no one just to have hear like other
people's stories good stories different
um like Journeys Journeys that people
have been on and I figured that when I
shared like I would start to hear from
more women who experienced the same
literally the same thing or something
extremely similar and I have it it's
been like very comforting to know like
this is just like something that happens
sometimes and we got to deal with it and
you're not like an outlier it's like a
thing yeah which like like I knew
because like that's what the doctor said
but it's different when like you know
people or you've heard yeah stories yeah
well I love you I love you dearly I'm so
glad you're here we're gonna give a
gorgeous episode I'm touched I feel so
untouched and uh that's another like
core memory opposite of childhood trauma
like whatever the opposite of that is
like core memory
um when we met The Veronicas at Nobu
when we were like we're in the city as
kids like for a big I think it was your
birthday right yeah a birthday
Extravaganza and we were obsessed with
The Veronicas that was like at their
Prime and we saw them and we took a
photo right yeah we did we gotta find
that one we always say that
yeah
so until we find it I think that we
should deliver yeah I think this Pastime
story is that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Mattress Firm so there are so many
things that can keep one up at night
we're calling them sleep disruptors
um for me it's you know dark thoughts
for others it's back pain whatever it is
um but that's why we took the mattress
matcher for Mattress Firm Mattress Firm
has the tools and expertise to help you
find the right mattress their sleep
experts receive over 200 hours of sleep
training to get you the Sleep solutions
that you deserve and to find a mattress
that fits your need so you can chat with
chat with one of their sleep experts in
store or online if you don't want to
talk in person sometimes it could be a
little embarrassing whatever you've got
going on that's keeping you up at night
and that's fine you can discover the
right mattress by using the online
mattress matcher their mattress firm's
online quiz will ask you questions about
your sleep preference and recommend a
high quality mattress at every price
point they help identify common sleep
disruptors like snoring tossing and
turning pain and all that can help you
find the right mattress so with Summer
here mattress firm's Memorial Day sale
is the place to find the perfect
mattress and bedding accessories for
better rest shop in store or online at
mattress firm.com I have been a mattress
firm girly my mattress that I have had
for many years is Mattress Firm and I'm
proud to say that I bought it on a
Memorial Day sale because I feel like
everyone thinks Memorial Day they think
barbecue
they think pool they think we can wear
white jeans now I'm thinking mattress
for Memorial Day sale it is the best
time to buy a mattress I literally
remember me and Ben were in the city and
we were we had just moved and we were
like looking for like stuff to do and
I'm like man we have to get a mattress
and really I think we went to a few
different stores matches for him had the
best pricing and the best sales and the
best mattresses it's lasted really long
I one thing about me I'm sleeping good
you know oh yeah she's not compromising
so you can shop in store online at
mattressfirm.com today's episode is also
brought to you by manscaped ladies June
is just around the corner and our guest
is that you haven't purchased a Father's
Day gift yet well look no further than
the sponsor of today's show because our
friends at manscaped are dedicated to
upgrading his grooming grooming game
from face to waste their brand new beard
hedger Pro kit is the total package
dedicated to making sure all fathers go
from dad to Daddy this year have him
join the 8 million men worldwide who
trust manscaped and get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code toast at
manscapes.com moms you're gonna like
this one
um whether you have you know a husband
who's a dad or you're blessed enough to
have your own dad what's that like check
out manscape.com so this package is
really going to make your dad the MVP of
his little group and it's going to make
you the MVP of the family the beard
hedger Pro kit so inside the package
you'll find the signature beard hedger
trimmer beard shampoo and conditioner
beard oil beard bomb and two free gifts
with their signature beard comb and
scissors with 20 hair cutting lengths
and a singular guard he'll be able to
craft his look like never before without
the mess in the drawers something all
the ladies can appreciate no more you
know cleaning up little tiny hairs that
you'll find for weeks on end the
lawnmower 4.0 is your game changer for
trimming in the sensitive areas and we
all know dads love their comfort if his
grooming routine is already dialed make
sure to hook him up with manscaped
boxers they are without a doubt the best
boxers for men of all ages get 20 off in
free shipping with code toast at
manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
toast make this Father's Day one he
won't forget and just like you know be
the number one girl in this group when
you get your dad the best gift this year
and then like he'll all year be like oh
my God I love this girl she's like the
best daughter yeah
I love that experience for you since
personally I can't experience that yeah
well Ben is Theo's Dad yeah
but Ben's got his manscaped oh he does
by the way he literally is the face of
manscaping he is and by the way not been
losing he I literally got him like the
whole package he loved the lawnmower for
his face this is actually not even a
sponsor anymore like that is over and he
was looking so Haggard and I'm like what
is wrong with you and he's like I lost
the thing he thought he left it in
Portugal and I'm like this [__]
like I can't bring anything into this
house cut two it was in his suitcase and
now he's back to looking better but like
if there were a few weeks ago where you
felt like Ben was looking like a little
Rusty that's why Rusty and crusty that's
Rusty Soffer that's so him okay our
first race some sad news to start off
the day I'm sorry Tina Turner has passed
away at the age of 83. Tina Turner the
iconic singer who was dubbed the queen
of rock and roll died on Wednesday May
24th at the age of 83. her publicist
confirmed to people that she died in her
home near Zurich Switzerland Tina Turner
the queen of rock and roll has died
peacefully today at the age of 83 after
a long illness in her home
um near Zurich Switzerland with her the
world loses a music legend and a role
model there will be a private funeral
ceremony attended by close friends and
family please respect the privacy of her
family at this difficult time the
statement says so sad she leaves behind
such a fabulous Legacy there were lizzo
at her concert last night did like a
Tina Turner tribute it was really
amazing and then that video of Beyonce
performing big wheels keep bone turning
at Tina Turner's like Kennedy Honors
like went viral last night and I watched
it it was like really spectacular
um I just feel like this is you know 83
is it's a good age to go like it's she
lived a long very very successful and
prosperous life but it's a huge loss for
the community yeah it is so many
tributes are coming like everyone's
posting about it everyone's sharing
another one that went viral which is one
of my favorites I don't think I ever
really realized it was Tina Turner is
the shit's creek of it all you know
Patrick and David's song is just simply
the best I call you when I need you
I love that one you come to me wild and
wild he like strips it down on a guitar
so I don't realize it's Tina Turner
until he goes you come to me give me
everything I need need You're simply the
best it's that's a really good one that
is a good one I didn't realize I hadn't
thought about that scene in so long and
I didn't realize it was Tina Turner
there's two so he remember when they
like closed down the the Apothecary
early and he just like dances for him
and it's like kind of weird but really
cute but then he also does like the
performance there's like a talent show
or something in the community and he
does it and I think that's when like
David realized like he really loves him
and it's a Moira is like behind David
like holding a shoulder it's literally
like the cutest thing ever and it's like
such a random song for them to have
chosen for that moment but it really is
perfect it is perfect uh then you know
when a major celebrity dies comes the
onslaught of a really inappropriate
social media behavior and I feel like
the last time we had this with Olivia
Newton John I believe it was I don't
know if I called it out on the
on the podcast we called out the idea of
rip Olivia rip Olivia but it was it was
garcelle on Twitter being like rip
Olivia like no other context it just
felt so
like what's the don't even share you
know yeah can't even write rest in peace
and we saw more of that behavior last
night and I'm gonna start calling people
out okay and because you know what yeah
the one I saw yesterday that you sent to
me not only was like
what they said rip Tina like just so
you're gonna like someone's entire life
into seven letters
but the format in which they posted it
on too I didn't even know people still
use this Instagram status update like
which is doesn't go to your whole feed
but just like the people who you
mutually follow and follow them they
were rip Tina I think there was like a
dub it was Blake Horseman like that's I
don't think there was a dove even oh let
me check well I don't even know that you
still followed Blake hearts and love
that for you I don't you do oh it was a
broken heart emoji even worse the dove
would have been more respectful yeah um
yeah because I kind of like I don't know
how to get out of following people
sometimes and I actually don't mind
following him because like him and
giannina I find really interesting and
like they're constantly doing things and
really into each other so that's not
someone I'm trying to unfollow but I
especially when someone follows me back
like I will follow them until I die yeah
okay well
I understand that's really bad I will
mute them yeah oh I am the queen of
muting people I only really unfollow
uh like if there's beef no because I
kind of like want to rise above the beef
and I'm like I'll still follow you yeah
no because I'm such a big person like
like I'm so mature I love to do that
yeah I'm so much like I literally can't
on top like no I love I love when
someone unfollows me and I like remain
following them I'm so mature yeah and
like I don't even see you unfollowing me
because I'm so busy I'm so busy being
mature Above This Petty nonsense I
completely agree I guess I would only
unfollow someone like if they posted
something that like I I thought was like
offensive offensive I'm offended
dangerous like goodbye I don't want to
see it or something like something that
like makes me upset I'm like I don't
want to be upset on my Instagram feed
today sir I said good day yeah
but for the most part I just follow
follow yeah no that's funny
um but what's not funny is Tina Turner
we're wishing her family well a great
legacy she leaves behind yes for sure
next up Taylor Swift announced
Midnight's Deluxe album with ice spice
and more Lana Del Rey so right after we
wrapped yesterday tailored posted that
she will be releasing a deluxe edition
of midnights titled midnights Till Dawn
that will feature ice spice as a guest
on her fresh version of Karma and newly
recorded vocals from Lana Del Rey on
their snow on the beach collaboration
because when that first song first came
out people were like where's Lana right
by the way I listened to that song
probably 50 times I never once heard
Lana was she silent or was she silenced
it's kind of like Chris Stapleton on the
other song yeah I bet you think about me
but since he has like a man's voice I
hear a little bit of like a Harmony from
like a lower register does he have a
verse no no no no okay that's what she
does like you all over me with Maron
Morris I am here Marin same with SD ham
hame in uh I think she did it but I
don't hear them yeah I love sitting on
the beach it's one of my favorite songs
from midnight so it's very clear to me
that Lana's missing yeah the other songs
I haven't like listened to as much so I
don't think about as much well I love
the concept of giving Karma like a new I
feel like this is a thing people did
like 10 years ago you would release a
song and then you would release it again
with like a really sick verse on it and
kind of how cardi B like brought that
Maroon 5 song back from the dead you
don't want a girl like me I'm too crazy
but every other girl you meet is fugazi
show the mother girls were nice enough
but you need someone to spice sit up so
Who you gonna call cardi cardi come and
rev it up like a Holly Holly why is the
best fruit always forbidden I'm coming
to you now doing 20 over the limit the
red light red light stop I don't play
when it comes to my heart keep trying I
don't need a white horse and a carriage
I need a white Porsches and carrots
whatever that was like literally one of
the best rap verses of all time and like
you can't tell me now and like nobody
even heard that song before cardi B was
on it I don't know about that no by the
way that song was [__] I think Maroon 5
has even said like we released this song
girls like you it flopped and then cardi
did it and then everyone loved the song
as a whole yeah like the ver they really
is a good song The Maroon 5 part and the
cardi song but I never would have heard
it without karting got it okay
interesting I didn't know that was the
history of the song yeah so I love this
concept of Karma like having a new
moment
for me though the big story from this
new version of midnights is hits
different yes so digital and physical
editions will each have a format
exclusive track for the digital release
it will be hits different a song that
was previously only available on the
target version of midnights more
interestingly for fans the physical
Edition will have a vault track never
before heard from the Midnight's writing
session and you'll be able to buy it at
MetLife so this is where Taylor annoys
me okay so it's like we waited months
and months for hits different which is
like one of these secret tracks finally
we're getting it only to find out that
there's another secret track that we
can't get unless and who the [__]
who knows how to play a CD I don't have
a car and most car things don't even
have cd things anymore yeah so like
let's say I even get I'm going to
MetLife let's say I get the C Day
what the [__] I gotta go get my Walkman
from Storage
I'm trying to think some computers still
accept it and then you can like burn it
onto your like laptop yeah what is this
like LimeWire you have to go to the
library no literally that's really crazy
but I can't really Express like the
Gratitude I feel for being able to
finally listen to it's different some
Angel goddess like ripped the audio from
their CD that they bought at Target like
Taylor does this thing where she puts
her best songs as like exclusive songs
at Target she has this partnership at
Target where she sells different
versions of her CDs at Target and you
get like an extra song new Romantics
literally one of her best songs nobody
heard for years because it was like a
Target thing now it's like on Spotify
and everything so she does this thing
it's so annoying but some Angel goddess
bought the target thing I don't want to
like blow up her spot but she put the
audio she like uploaded
a podcast to Spotify but it's just
the song so it's like the hits different
podcast but it like everything else was
getting taken down but I think when she
put it up as a podcast I listened to it
for a while I'm not sure if it's still
up but she was acquainted
um
and now we're finally gonna get it like
I've been dying to like pop my [__]
into that song well now's your chance
and the all-new song on the physical
midnight MetLife album is called you're
losing me which is feeling like Joe
maybe we would understand why Joe lost
her
I chase the artifacts cried over a hat
find the space that I'm needing
I'm excited yeah it's exciting I'm
excited for the karma remix because
karma is like one of those songs it's
like not my favorite actually no sorry
I'm confusing it with vigilante [__] for
a second
um but still Karma's not my favorite but
it's like really strong and solid and I
think it just needs to be like punched
up one or two notes karma is a song like
I liked in the beginning but it really
it didn't rise to the top once I really
got to know the whole album however the
tour made me like it so much that's what
I've heard I heard it also more people
like vigilantees no I vigilante [__]
will and always be like not my favorite
song and I don't know why it made it
onto the eras tour setlist I think
because it's the one you can have fun
with it's so descriptive and it's like
well she does like a very sexy dance
with a chair on tour to the song so like
people are loving that but it's not
it's not giving what it needs to be
giving also speaking of Taylor we need
to talk about the fact that she was out
in New York one of Claudia's frequent
haunts but to make you feel better like
you were never going to be there was
night one of the inner public of course
not I was not getting dressed I was not
staying alert and it's almost like she
knew like all the thirst monsters would
be inside watching Vanderpump Rules so
she would be free to roam the restaurant
in peace genius
I feel it felt personal
her going out to a restaurant I go to
all the time that's actually the
restaurant I went to to look for her
when I was getting dressed and staying
alert
it's her fault
and like it's over
because her first concert is tomorrow in
New York so she's not gonna go out
tonight like she's got to prepare so
like her week in New York like it's over
I can't like maybe she go after New York
that is a very good question maybe she's
still on the Eastern seaborg
yeah like at some point when she's like
in L.A she's not gonna be coming back to
New York no but she's been like a New
England Queen these last Rachel she goes
to Boston she comes back she goes to
Philly she comes back because even
though she has her house in Rhode Island
I don't know why oh yeah the Rhode
Islanders were saying that she was going
to be spending the week in Rhode Island
Chicago's next she'll definitely come
back you think Chicago's like an hour
flight where where's after Chicago
Detroit Michigan that's also like a
quick flight
um Pittsburgh she'll definitely come
back
Minneapolis
Matt Healy where does where is he based
UK he's based in the UK yeah then Kansas
UK is like New York
yeah well because when you travel to the
States from the UK going to La is
literally an additional six hours after
a six hour flight but I just feel like
New York and London like are friends
they are and they're like very similar
cities I feel like if you like London
you like New York yeah they're like
fast-paced meet people like I feel like
londoners could like look down on La
definitely not want to spend a lot of
time there definitely so that's good for
New York yeah
and Taylor has like a good setup in New
York I think in Rhode Island she does
not get a lot of privacy like everybody
knows where her house is and it's not
like protected in a sense like people
can go to the beach and like see her
house and yeah they're far but it's
weird in New York she like bought that
whole block she has her own garage she
pulls in she like she has it made in the
shade Plus
it's still a little cold to head to the
beach the beach and Rhode Island like I
don't think it's The Season's not in
full swing yet that's why Memorial Day
After The Mattress Firm sale like maybe
she'll head over there and by the way
this is like the greatest time to be in
New York in like a month or two New York
is insufferable it's so hot and smelly
she will not be back she will not be
back but right now it's like the best
weather she's been wearing like
Cardigans like not just like me yeah no
puffy jackets she's really here at like
the high season yeah so I think she'll
be here for like the next few weekends
until Summer's in full swing and then
she'll go to her summer house yeah where
she Summers where she Summers
okay yeah you still have I said there's
a chance so you're saying there's a
chance there is a chance I think I
believe in you thank you it was just
tough because like I have gotten dressed
and I have stayed alert
all for not all for naught and I like
went to the place I had a blowout last
night please you are making me feel
worse but you couldn't have you had to
work yeah no I just also even when I
people were dming me because I guess
they were like waiting outside Claudia
she's here she's here
no part of me even felt compelled to go
like I was I had tanned my face I was
bare-faced I was laying in bed with Theo
I was eating
a fudgesicle like there was no way
I understand I'm kind of in my popsicle
era they're really good no they really
are like I'm in my like pint of ice
cream era actually which is so I've
never really done it before but now like
I kind of sit down I don't eat the I
like probably eat a third every time I
sit down with it what flavor
I like dolce de leche you're doing
talenti I do talenti and Haagen-Dazs
um 20's a little healthier so like you
could have a little more sure no like
the calories on the back yeah they speak
for themselves like the whole thing is
like 700 something oh my God where is
hogging those it's like a thousand
something that's what it is so but is it
more quantity
and that's the same quantity but it's
gelato it's not ice which was like made
with real stuff allegedly it's like real
cream not like yeah synthetics yeah oh
last night I had um banana pudding from
Magnolia Bakery oh yum I did like the
popsicle brand like the thing about me
when it comes to popsicles like I want
the All-American popsicle brand like I
don't need these newfangled Brands you
know yeah the ones made with like Greek
yogurt no no no even though those
awesome ones like are very good but I
like when I go especially in the
summertime I'm feeling real American
popsicle brand all the way like the ones
that come in a pack of two and you rip
them apart that and outshine brand those
are my favorites I'm just kind of in my
popsicle era it's just so nice to get
into bed like with a popsicle yeah it's
like a snack and also like a game
no it's a fun way to snack yeah and it's
like how long can I suck on this you
know and it's like is it gonna fall on
my shirt it's just like exciting is Theo
gonna have the best night ever yeah with
the fruity ones I do give Theo a few
legs the chocolate ones never and then
you lick it back yourself
no usually when I'm at the end of it
like I let him go I was trying to think
like do I actually do that no I don't
okay good it's like kind of gross yeah
great are you ready for our next story
yeah
Margot Robbie reveals the dorky actress
that turned down Barbie oh I saw this
Margot Robbie revealed she tried to cast
Israeli beauty queen gal Godot in her
upcoming Blockbuster because she had
such strong Barbie energy but the
actress turned her down she said in her
Vogue cover which is like so cute and
adorable some quotes are coming out but
this was you know one of the best
factoids she said Gal Gadot was so
impossibly beautiful but you don't hate
her for being that beautiful because
she's so genuinely sincere and she so
enthusiastically kind that it's almost
dorky it's like right before being a
dork so she asked her to Star as Barbie
in the Barbie movie
um but she wasn't available to shoot the
film it was likely that she was busy
filming other projects including
um Greta gerwig's upcoming Snow White
Film oh I didn't realize she was working
with Greta Gerwig on Snow White which is
interesting as we were discussing
yesterday because we know Gal Gadot is
an extremely you know gorgeous Israeli
Queen and Greta wig like hates Israel so
it's just nice to see Greta getting past
her biases to work with talented
actresses so I went because when I first
read this I was like Greta Gerwig has
said had made some anti-israel comments
in the past she like signed this letter
of like trying to boycott like an
Israeli artist and so I was I just
assumed that that's why like wouldn't
want to work with her
um so I went to see like what she did
originally
that like you know sparked all of this
but she has since expressed regret she
like signed a letter with 60 other
people trying to boycott the Lincoln
Center from having this like artist come
because oh my God it was like Israeli
and and his production was like
sponsored by like the Israeli cultural
like tourism or whatever yeah and so 60
people signed the letter and she was one
of them but then she later expressed
regretted signing the letter and she
said
um that
she's generally careful about causes
that she supports but in this case she
was not she was unfamiliar with the
complexities of the letter and did not
take the time to study them okay you
know what Santa Queen who can and when
she said when she's wrong all right I
take back what I said
um having said that I love galgado and I
do not think she's right for this role
and that's
I'm trying to think whether it's like I
can only Envision someone who's blonde
in this role but I just don't think
she's right for it I could see why what
Margot Robbie's talking about because
she can be very like silly I feel like
that's how she was in Wonder Woman She's
like this gorgeous Amazon woman and
she's like kind of dumb like yeah like I
feel like that's how she would play it
and I'm good on that like I'm not
looking to see that yeah I feel like I
could see that movie and it's like it
would be annoying because even in Wonder
Woman she got to be like a little
annoying she's like this big dope
walking around with her sword and her
shield and she's like can't even like
see herself right you didn't see one no
I didn't see Wonder Woman but if you saw
it it's like good but there's just
something weird about her portrayal of
it where she's just a big dope okay and
I feel like that's what that when when
Robert says is what she's describing
when she says dorky I say Dopey for sure
um I just feel like with the Barbie
movie like it was always meant to be
Margot Robbie I know Amy Schumer was
originally cast that didn't feel right
that feels right no I love the Amy
Schumer casting because it was like it
would have been a totally different it
would have been elf Barbie Edition by
the way obsessed with that concept
obsessed and the thing about this Barbie
movie is that still people like don't
know what the plot is right right
because the Amy Schumer one and at first
it was being like thrown around is it
being like elf like she's cast out of
Barbie land because she's like an
outcome or like that Amy Adams One
Enchanted yeah which I love that those
are all amazing and that's funny it
works and it would work with Barbie so
they've said that that's not what this
is but like
in the trailer it looks like at one
point they're in Barbie land and then at
one point there's a real world yeah and
that they like Escape together Barbie
and Ken yeah I mean I feel like there's
a lot of talk about you know who would
have or could have or should have played
Barbie and I feel like there's not
enough talk about who should have played
Ken because I don't think Ryan Gosling
is right for it who should have played
him
somebody younger
I'm sorry like
they're supposed to be like Flawless
right Margot Robbie is a Flawless human
being
he's aging well but he's not flawless
wow like a Jacob a lordy type you know
like he's a perfect specimen
I hadn't thought much Austin Butler
a perfect specimen he'll start with like
walking around dead award show oh my God
literally sorry guys I don't have any
joints thanks nice to meet you
so method so method also the Barbie
album tracklist came out yes and it's
filled with
but Taylor's not on it right no there
was so much speculation like pretty much
in the swimsuit Community it was
confirmed that she was going to be a
part of it and a lot of people thought
that it's different was being saved for
the soundtrack got it well they put out
like this lineup of the art album artist
Ava Max Charlie XTX Dominic Fike
duolippa 5050 Gail Heim I spice Cali
Carol G Khalid lizzo Nicki Minaj Pink
Panthers Ryan Gosling Tame Impala and
the kid Leroy then it says more Barbies
and Ken's to be announced to maybe
Taylor's still in the running yeah that
could be there's an announcement there
are some you know highlights on there
it's not like so star-sided as I thought
but like Nicki Minaj I spice it's strong
and it's being produced by Mark Ronson
oh which is all the faith I will sit
down and put the album on like while I
do my makeup and give it a shot yeah and
I'm sure they're gonna do the the Barbie
song right we had a story about this I
don't think that they are remember we
talked about this who sings it
originally Aqua Aqua I think we should
get them back together I know but there
was a story that said this song will not
be used in the movie period I mean
that's moronic I feel like Nicki Minaj
could have done like a really cool new
I'm a Barbie like something cool like
that I don't know I'm not an artist just
like just throwing some ideas out there
throwing some stuff out there like I
feel like super basic her Super Bass era
her fans are literally called barbs like
no I know that's why she's on the out no
of course but like she should have done
like honestly Beyonce and Nicki Minaj
on the Barbie song that would have been
cool
but we'll get new Barbie music I know
but like it's a classic for a reason I'm
a Barbie girl
in a Barbie world
yeah honestly it's so iconic like life
in plastic it's fantastic just the the
song itself the lyrics Come on Barbie
let's like every lyric Come on Barbie
let's go party
oh yeah like it's so good yeah huge
mistake
I'm sure there's reasons yeah and they
got their reasons
just like you um what'd you do when you
walked out of my life and you didn't
have to what'd you send me send me real
in
what can you do there's nothing I can do
about what about you taking my heart and
breaking it right into
I love that man love like bullets
it's been hard for me this week to not
listen to Luke Combs while I get ready
because I'm like in my podcast and I
just I miss him well I'm in my walking
era I don't know if I told you about the
I walk now every day here in two two and
from because you're free because the
laptop I'm free of my laptop and I just
have my purse with like lip gloss
sunglasses chapstick a fan sucking candy
got some Rolos in there and I Feel Free
as a bird so I am now listening to music
when I walk what's your soundtrack my
liked songs right now are the Luke Combs
and Ed Sheeran song which is so good I
think it's called life goes on
um I actually forgot to add that to my
liked have you been listening to Kelly
no add her to your like I know I'm
[__] up one of her songs both of them
are kind of like ballety and emo but
like if you love Kelly like they're so
powerful um but one of them has a remix
so if you need like a pep in your step
okay okay like you did mine and I've
been listening to next thing you know I
love that song I haven't fallen into it
yet but I'm sure to you by the way in
two years I'll be playing in my car
saying have you heard of this one no
it's like a song it's so sweet like I
heard him I've heard it before it's like
it goes viral and ticked up but then I
saw him perform it at the acms and I
actually listened right yeah I listen to
all the words and it's so
like emotional like you're gonna cry no
I know but I'm still hung up on by dirt
Badger than the one you can't live
without what'd you do give me let your
ring in the ground get a knee let your
ring hit there that's pregnancy baby do
what you love because what are you gonna
throw throw a little money in the plate
at church what are you gonna send send
his prayers up and your roots down deep
add in the limbs to your family tree by
the way we interviewed him on the ACM
red carpet and he's like oh I just was
watching your guys on Tick Tock getting
ready for the thing he was like you came
up on my fyp I'm like that makes me
think like who else is fyp am I coming
up on toast Clips like
Kylie
you never know that's the beauty of tick
tock depends how much time she spends on
it I always think about like celebrities
who like some of them probably like
mindlessly scroll Tick Tock and they
just see like civilians yeah they see
like you and Ben popping each other's
pimples
is that exciting yeah I never thought of
that that's all I think about are you
ready for our next story yeah because
the Kardashians premiered last night yes
I did not get a chance to watch it but
Claudia did she's going to do a mini
recap and also talk about some of the
biggest Bombshells that came out from
the episode one in which being that Kim
reacted to Kanye accusing her of
cheating with Drake yeah so at the end
of the episode Kim like sat down with
Chris and she had like had a really bad
day and she's just like I don't know why
everyone like can't keep their [__]
together so I'm like I'm always the one
who has to keep their [__] together and
she's just saying what we know nothing
new just basically like
you know the kids one day will
appreciate that I didn't say anything
they get in the car and they want to
listen to Daddy's music and I jam out
with them and it's like so hard for me
and I know I'm doing the right thing but
like I'm also human and she said like I
can take it when he comes for me yada
yada but
he's been coming after Chris at this
point and like that's really hard for
Kim she like feels this responsibility
to protect everyone and that makes her
want to fight back and Chris is like
you're fine you're fine
um
but also what was interesting and I
guess I didn't really think about he was
going on at the time that they're
filming this like he was going off just
like kept bringing up her sex tape and
she's like you know the way he is acting
down the road like the kids will see
that and they will be far more
embarrassed of the way he's acting than
like of my sex tape which I made when I
was 18 and like was clearly a mistake
like it was she had a really good head
on her shoulders about it but she's like
where like her patience is wearing thin
yeah and she was like you know he keeps
saying he's my protector he's my
protector but like the whole time we
were married like he was the one
perpetuating that rumor that I [__]
I'm like was having an affair with Drake
during our marriage and that whole Kiki
do you love me thing like that was him
so like why how he can say he was my
protector and now continue to say he's
my protectors like are you delusional
like yeah you're not yeah she said the
one that was supposed to protect me and
still does interviews saying that they
will be my forever protector is the one
that's hurting me the most he was the
one that started a rumor that I was
hooking up with Drake having an affair
our whole marriage he accused me of that
publicly I really can't wrap my head
around how he thinks he's a protector
yeah no it's just like it's it's that
everyone has been there when you're just
like arguing with someone who's not
rational it's like it's not it's
pointless then it's like Kim's name
being dragged to the mud and I hope Kim
has like peace knowing like during the
times when Kanye has been like on his
you know spiral nobody really believes
what he says so you know there's solace
in knowing that well I think a lot of
his fans do like but I think he has his
own fans and Kim has her own fans and I
think there are some people who are fans
of both of them who have to like you
know within themselves parse out like
what they think is true but I think like
his fans believe what he says like about
her but the like we're primarily Kim
fans and I'm like
we don't know the half of anything yeah
no and like the fact that she's like
talking about this rumor about Drake
means it's not true like if she had an
affair with Drake she wouldn't have
brought it up you know well she didn't
say that she didn't did you no she
called it a rumor like yeah she didn't I
don't think that she did but um but I
think even if she did say but like it's
the fact that he keeps bringing it up
right that it doesn't die because
because he's bringing it up whether or
not it's true or false and that's the
same with the sex tape I think like Kim
gets so mad every time he brings up the
sex tape like one because like they have
kids together and all the obvious
reasons but also because she's and she
had said like
every time you bring it re-bring it up
it's like you remind people she like
feels like she's made so much progress
like as a businesswoman as a lawyer as a
mom and she's
gets far away from the sex tape thing
that to the point where people for many
years like didn't even think about it
but now it's like you keep bringing it
up you remind people yeah agree but I
also feel like she brings it up
sometimes like she because I think it's
so in the Forefront for her like on SNL
she was like bringing it up in her
monologue and I just like was like we're
I moved on we're past it yeah well I
think she like is afraid of everyone
talking about it so she makes the joke
first especially at SNL yeah yeah well
I'm really excited to watch that's
really sad yeah um it was like a crazy
bombshell episode was it enjoyable
watching it was just great to see the
girls back there's like something going
on with Chloe and it's like there's like
that's there's an undercurrent too she's
talking about she has this melanoma
situation which I think ends up being
really serious
um
but something really I think like very
honest that she spoke about that um I
was shocked it's like a very vulnerable
thing and she's like she's really having
trouble at this point in the show like
connecting with her son she's like
nobody talks about this part of
surrogacy and like I wish somebody had
like
I didn't like fully I kind of buried my
head in the sand when she was pregnant
the surrogate and then it's like I just
go to the hospital and come home with a
baby and it's weird and you know Kim
didn't experience this so I don't really
have anyone to like commiserate with
she's like I wish more people spoke
about like there's a weird element of
surrogacy I thought it was like so brave
because I think it's
not similar but similar to like uh
postpartum like you can't connect with
the baby and hers are obviously for
different reasons but she's going
through something and she's like just
not herself and she's so thin and like
she is also dealing with this health
thing and she's just not being her like
fun Chloe self yeah but I also feel like
if you like last season she was already
not in a great place and so yeah
to then go through a health situation
and welcome a new baby and like not be
starting out at a hundred yeah it can
like really drain you like they had this
event and she sat next to James Corden
and honestly I was like loving the James
Corden he was being like so funny she
loves him yeah and like he was being so
funny and she's just like you could tell
like the smile like the giggle like it
was like just very like social like it
wasn't it wasn't genuine no like she's
really been struggling yeah no I I fell
for her deeply and then like Courtney
was going on and on about how like
everyone in the family she said it in
her interviews and then she repeated
what she said to Chloe when they were
having this one-on-one she was like I
feel like the family's really good at
you know celebrating each other and
having fun together and lifting each
other up but when the time comes for
someone who's like going through
something dark or grieving like we don't
know how to be there for each other and
I was like okay and then she repeated
that like a couple days later to Chloe
and Chloe was like what Chloe's like I
feel like
one that's not true feel like I I
actually am so there for everyone like
it was just like a weird take that
I wonder Chloe clearly disagreed with
and I wonder if everyone else disagrees
with too I also feel
like for you in a tough time it would be
Chloe like because she's one there for
everyone but two like she's been through
she's been through and not to compare
but like the most and most recently and
like if she feels like her family is
there and supporting her
right now like what instances Courtney
talking about where she didn't get that
right I felt like maybe that was
Courtney's like like a reflection of how
Courtney felt but not necessarily
indicative of the whole family you know
but what has Courtney been going through
or like needing support that she didn't
get
um they they struggled with uh fertility
she opened up as she's done with IVF
they did three rounds she had Frozen her
eggs at 38 and 39 actually I thought
this was a good point that she makes
like everybody talks about egg freezing
like it's the safety net and nobody
really talks about how like you can
freeze your eggs and then hers didn't
make it through the thawing process so
it's like if it's spoken about like this
foolproof safety net and that's what she
had thought and she was like really you
know sad to learn like her eggs didn't
make it to into embryos because they
didn't survive the thawing process oh
that I didn't know I knew that embryos
are more secure like if you freeze
embryos versus eggs yeah but I didn't
realize that like you could freeze your
eggs and not have an egg right so that's
probably something she now now she's at
the place where she's like you know what
if God want it like we're just [__]
all the time and if God wants it it will
happen but like I'm not going to
continue to do the hormones and take
that toll on my body physically and
mentally I feel like she had a really
good head on her shoulders about the
whole thing um but I'm sure that was
tough for her yeah I know like her and
Travis really want to have a baby so she
felt like in that situation she wasn't
referencing that directly but you had
said like what has she been through and
like you know what you never know and
that's something I think that was
probably really tough on her
interesting but they're they're speaking
about how like they're being very open
about how like Chloe and Kim are like
the new Chloe and Courtney they've been
saying that for years though yeah and um
they're like planning this day and I
think it'll be next week where it's like
Chloe and Courtney take Calabasas and
they like do crazy things Chloe and
Courtney yeah is that what I said yeah
yeah yeah like they're trying to get
their mojo back
but then in the um in the trailer for
next week Courtney said something that
was like a kind of mean and like be kind
of delusional she was like
you know when we were younger there was
always this like very good competitive
nature between Kim and I which I think
was like natural and the Very sisterly
and I just don't think Kim has let that
go like I have and it's like okay sure
recording like okay and it's all about
the Dolce Gabbana thing got it that
looks like the hottest teeth that's
still coming out what we know is
Courtney's married already in this where
we're at the wedding's over and Kim is
designing they want to do like however
the creative director for a season
design and walk and like plan the show
and it will be I think
five months after her wedding The
Collection won't come out until nine
months but the show will be five months
after her wedding
okay and Kim is having reservations
about it Chris is like you have to do it
it's such an amazing opportunity and Kim
is like I know it's an amazing
opportunity but like I am feeling a
certain way about it and I don't think
Courtney knows yet because of Courtney
yeah yeah and I don't think Courtney
knows yet okay so I didn't realize that
Kim like recognizes first that there's a
weirdness to it right but it's also
interesting they gave backstory the
whole relationship between the girls the
family and the gabbanas is through Chris
not Kim not Courtney no no not Courtney
I never thought it was Courtney I
thought it was Chris I would just assume
I mean I thought it was Kim uh no I
thought it was Court Courtney Kim had
never worked with dng before yeah but
Chris was always going like there was
like a like there was something there
was yeah something but like when Chris
went to the ultimota remember that in
Venice like Courtney and Travis were
there yeah but Chris had gone so [__]
hard to talk about these people Chris
had gone many years in a row before that
okay she was always going to Florence
with Simon like always okay so I could
have guessed if you had asked like maybe
and I sat down and thought about it
it being Chris makes the most sense
which really means the relationship
belongs to Chris and belongs to all the
sisters equally so if Chris is blessing
it but she's really encouraging him to
do it then I think it's kosher okay I
didn't know it was Chris's I thought it
was Courtney said Courtney kind of
brought like dng to the family and the
family to dng and then like they plucked
Kim from that and that kind of no I
would have to assume that like when Kim
when Courtney was looking for
someone for her wedding to design and
like be they went through their roster
of connects Chris brought Dolce to the
table and Courtney liked it yeah so it's
Chris's relationship to Dole out okay
that changes things for me it doesn't I
think it makes it a better case for Kim
100 100
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story that's gonna lead into our
TV recap of Vanderpump Rules this is the
fifth final story that's gonna lead into
our TV recap of rules that's brought to
you by the perfect bar tis this episode
is brought to you by the perfect bar the
original refrigerated protein bar that
you know and love today is a very
exciting day because perfect bar is
launching a new line of protein bars
called perfect bar layers so the perfect
bar layers are a new line of crispy
protein bars that are stacked with three
delicious layers and packed with whole
food nutrition they're made with Crispy
base of peanut butter and cashew butter
they're layered with dark chocolate or
100 real fruit and then they're
sprinkled with toasted gluten-free oats
they're packed with up to 11 grams of
protein and they come in two delicious
flavors crispy peanut butter and
chocolate and crispy peanut butter and
Berry they're basically a healthy peanut
butter and jelly they are so delicious
they're also refrigerated because
they're made with you know only the best
of the best whole food ingredients
they're classic blend of over 20 Super
Foods they contain no artificial
preservatives and they are of course
stored in the fridge we have some here
they're perfect to just have around at
home at the office whenever you need
like a boost throughout the day you're
hungry you need energy you just need to
feel like you can make it through the
day perfect bar is always there for you
if you aren't already convinced they're
also non-GMO project verified
gluten-free soy free kosher and low GI
perfect bar layers are now available to
purchase online and we have an exclusive
link just for toasters when you go to
perfect snacks.com use code toast for 15
off your first order what's very
exciting is that we've been working with
perfect Bar for a long time we've been
able to get you free perfect bars but
now we have a code which we haven't had
yet so perfect snacks.com the code is
toast for 15 off your order here
can't wait to hear what you guys think
of the new perfect bar layers at perfect
snacks.com code toast today's episode is
also brought to you by Lulu the
Lululemon shorts specifically they were
made to stretch flex and support the
infinite ways of working out giving you
the courage to LEAP into something
totally new and unexpected so they have
a bunch of shorts available at Lululemon
for men and for women and here are some
of our favorites the hottie hot short
it's the short with a comfortable range
of motion and a flattering fit they
allow you to Max your stride so you can
move freely with confidence the
lightweight Swift fabric lets in airflow
so you can move without baggage they're
designed to Wick away sweat before you
even notice that it's there the Wonder
train short is also a favorite of ours
the short with supportive stretch that
also keeps you dry it's powered by
everlux fabric the Wonder train
collection manages heat and sweat so you
stay comfortable and focused the Fabrics
is super breathable it absorbs it
absorbs moisture and Wicks sweat during
the even most intense training also the
pace breaker short which is one of their
best-selling men's shorts great for
Father's Day gift or just someone in
your life The Versatile short is up to
any challenge the ultra lightweight
fabric means you can train move and
stretch how you want without the baggage
each pair of pace breaker shorts is
designed to Wick away moisture so all
that's left is your intention that's the
best part of Lululemon they're an
athleisure brand that you can trust
um with shorts with the hot summer
coming up it's really tough to be
walking around with like your crevices
moist crevices
undercarriage sweat crotch sweat
whatever you want to call it it's a
tough time swamp ass is my favorite it's
a tough time of year so make sure you're
prepared make sure you're prepared
Jackie okay with moisture wicking
material the shorts from Lululemon
whether you're working out running to
the grocery store don't let
undercarriage sweat get to you get into
Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com thank
you you're welcome our fifth and final
story a little Vanderpump adjacent news
before we get into the recap of reunion
part one Andy Cohen crashes of
Vanderpump Rules reunion watch party and
take shots with fans so Andy joined in
on the camaraderie and surprised a group
of fans watching the highly anticipated
reunion in New York City on Wednesday he
posted on his Instagram story saying I
got an invite to crash of Vanderpump
Rules viewing party which is like a
block from my house so he and his
co-host John Hill from SiriusXM Radio
Andy grab dinner at Via carota before
deciding to crash The Bash he said okay
we're doing it I just want to say this
is just going to be a drop by but we'll
see I also would like to see if they
have any desserts yeah they showed up I
felt like they had smoked pot before
because they're walking up Andy
Instagram storied the whole thing he's
like I hope they have dessert I'm so
hungry and John is like I'm starving but
they just came from dinner but maybe
they didn't get something sweet after
and that's something that is relatable
when I have a dinner I need something
sweet sweet I need a sweet treat to top
it off oh 100 but I just read Andy's
book and he pretty much like smokes pot
every night so he was definitely like
munching got it but they were also just
like having a good time he brought a
bottle so cute pre-made negronis and
buzzed the buildings Bell
um then they swim in like screamed well
the girl the girl whose apartment it was
I think she knew that Eddie was going to
show up so she she opened the bell for
him and like they quietly like trotted
down the hall and the girls were
freaking it wasn't like a crazy watch
party there's maybe three or four five
people and they were freaking and Andy
like beelined for the table he was like
do you have any desserts yeah they did
shots together had a overall good time
that's really crazy it was really sweet
I think there's like a lot of um people
who've interacted with Andy who would
say like he's not like super nice like I
think people like he's one of those
celebrities that has like like not you
know great like rep okay
um but this is really endearing I think
she give back to the community where and
when you catch him like if he's if
you're like and how you approach him
like I feel like in his personal life
he's probably like a really nice guy but
like if he's working and someone's
coming up to him like maybe he's not the
nicest or maybe on a bad day and I feel
like you said he talks about it in his
book like he maybe has like a short fuse
and is quick to like be a little
rude no but also I think he's a rude
person he's the head of like the Bravo
universe and Bravo fans can be like very
overbearing and maybe like you know
invade invasive a little bit so he
definitely deals with a lot I wasn't
saying that he's like a mean guy
um but I feel like when you catch him in
the right environment somewhere where he
wants to be like he went to these people
he made the choice place like you're
gonna get a good Andy yeah yeah yeah it
was very sweet but I don't think he's
like 100 rude 100 of the time no no I
also think we got a good Andy the day of
the reunion I think he was like loving
that like this was going to be like one
of the most watched reunions of all time
everybody really showed up to the
reunion last night like wanting to leave
their mark and it ended up causing a
little bit too much of chaos agreed
let's get into the reunion that's
exactly what I thought too like everyone
wanted to speak everyone had their
one-liners everyone's upset and thinks
that they're the most the most upset
they're like James being like you were
with my ex-fiance and it's like I forgot
that James like that element of it and
that James and Tom Sandoval were friends
like everyone just wanted their moment
in the Sun and like I just wish everyone
could have calmed down a little and I
swear I feel like that's what we said
the day that they were filming that
everyone was like on their best like
everyone was just like too hyped up and
it's they're gonna film for 10 hours you
will say your piece like but just let
people speak no I will say I probably I
think the person on the best behavior
was either Katie or Sheena like they
were the only people who didn't just
like interject so much James and Lala
were really funny but like towards the
end they were really annoying me like
most of the conversations that were
being had were actually not about them
and if we could just let like Schwartz
Sandoval Ariana and like a little bit of
Katie if we could let them get in and
like figure it out like that would be
great even Lisa was like talking more
than she needed to and I know she
probably felt she needed to be like
Peacemaker and defend not defend but
like
help Tom Sandoval out a little a little
I actually did appreciate that because
everyone's screaming at one person is
not interesting it's not interesting
it's not helpful not letting him respond
I will say it was funny though when he
like first the first thing he said he
started to cry oh my God and James was
like shut up like that was truly funny
but I kind of like went downhill from
there it was a little too chaotic I
agree and there are moments in reunions
when like it gets to that place and it's
so chaotic and everyone's screaming over
each other Andy yells and everyone comes
down but from start to finish Lisa was
like we're gonna be here for 10 hours it
was the very beginning for it to be like
that from the start was like a little
overwhelming yeah hard to follow it's
like who should I be listening to when
everyone's talking over each other and
disappointing because
they're starting to like fumble the
situation a little bit but I actually
enjoyed strangely because we said so
many times we don't want to talk about
the rest of the season yes when they
segued into conversations about the rest
of the season we were able to have like
a normal reunion conversations and also
everything is like scandival adjacent
like Sheena no now it's all layered it's
all layered but I felt like hearing from
Sheena was really interesting about
um I feel bad for Sheena I feel so bad
for Sheena it probably feels so stupid
yeah and next week when she said in the
trailer for next week that she's trusted
her husband in bed with Raquel like
crazy
these people are [__] crazy like that
is that first of all she's Jezebel yeah
but even if she were like the person
that you thought that she was like what
are you doing like why is your husband
in bed with your friends and I want to
say in defense of Sheena like I actually
feel like everybody minimizes like the
history of the group
people really do forget like how Sheena
was such an outsider for so long and I
do now really understand why she felt so
protective of Raquel of course she
didn't know Raquel was going to end up
being this Jezebel I understand why she
maybe saw a little bit of herself in
Raquel and
the the way that she just even Lala
being like Bully's a strong word no
actually bully is the perfect word like
they were so mean to her I do understand
Sheena a little bit more after last
night and and I don't blame her as much
for vehemently taking Raquel's side it
really wasn't about Raquel versus Katie
it was about like her own trauma right I
feel like historically she's always
taken the side of the new girl like even
when Ariana came in like she had her
back when Lala came in Sheena had her
back when Charlie came in Sheena cozied
up to her she also always has her weird
other intentions yeah like going on but
I think the core of it is that she wants
to protect new girls against this like
uh mean girl mentality that she
experienced but I do think in certain
situations it's like a phantom mentality
that she's creating based on what
happened to her because not everything
is the same thing as what happened to
her yeah I just and Andy did ask this
there is a conversation worth having
about the hypocrisy in the group of
course as it pertains to Tom Sandoval
and the fact like nobody would hear
anything like about like any time
anything was brought up from Seasons
past whether it's James and Kristen
whether it's Lala and James like
whether it was about cheating or not
like it was automatically shut down by
the group and there really is a
conversation worth having and you you
need the context of the group and
everyone just did that I was 21 like no
actually
no the thing is there is a scale and
what Tom and Raquel did is the worst of
it but like other people have landed
Elsewhere on the scale but I do think
that you could like say yeah I made a
mistake but if it's a one-time thing
versus like a seven month Affair like
they're no it's so much a mistake versus
like a conscious diabolical
psychotic situation it's it's different
but yeah no we're not all Angels sitting
here but like you're actually the devil
and I really wish everything had just
slowed down a bit because like you know
there was so
Tom Sandoval told Andy the day before
that Schwartz didn't know until January
and Schwartz said no you told me
remember in August so I think they're
both unfortunately like they're both
kind of telling the truth because
Schwartz didn't know that they were
having an affair until January but
Schwartz did know in August that they
had sex once no but Tom Sandoval like
intentionally lied to Andy like
manipulated language yeah but there
wasn't an affair to know about in August
like when did but they [__] I know but
like that's not them that one time [__]
like that which is horrible is not
the thing that we're almost mad about
which is the seven month affair right
under your girlfriend yeah but Tom
Sandoval like he knew because he knew
that they had [__] and then he had
Schwartz excuse me he knew that they had
[__] and then he had said that thing
to Katie like yeah he had his suspicions
right so Sandoval did lie and so I just
feel like if the whole group like slowed
down a little bit we could have gotten
more out of it but I do think he told
him once in August and once in January
and they're talking about two separate
things yeah I just wish everyone had
slowed down like overall for the whole
reunion like yeah and just like let
Sandoval speak even though he is a worm
with a mustache like let him bury
himself yeah
let him I did kind of love the concept
of having a camera on Raquel even though
she didn't say anything
her facial reaction she said was like
eating it up it was like obsessed and
also she's like liking hearing her the
boys the boys both of them yeah like
talk about her like oh I want to know
what he thinks about me like yeah no it
was diabolical yeah
and I honestly it was fine it was a good
episode but we need to hear from her I
feel like everything even the sit down
with Ariana and Tom like we've heard all
of this now between watch Robin's live
all the podcasts I we have not heard
from Raquel no and that is what I need
yeah I need a one-on-one with Raquel
yeah because you know when she comes on
everyone's going to be yelling at her I
know and it's like honestly she deserves
to be yelled at she's the devil for sure
but can we hear like I'm curious yeah I
really need everyone to calm the [__]
down no I know it's
it's too much and we knew it would it
would be everyone was just really James
and all that it was great at first but
at the end it got tired coming for
everyone including Lisa yeah no and like
just like speak when spoken to because
anytime someone asked Lala a question
like when Andy asked um Lala about
just he asked a random question that you
know
about Randall leaving their house and
then Lyle actually made a great
comparison between Tom and Randall like
how you can never get him to stay home
but then one should hit the fan like
they couldn't get him to leave the house
and I thought that was so interesting so
it's like just your time will come to
say your peace just wait yeah but I fear
I mean this is part one I feel it's
gonna stay this chaotic the whole time
yeah
and I don't know why they've been
they've done so many reunions like don't
you know like just how it works it's
always best it's a slow burn like let it
get there to come out so hot and not I
couldn't hear anything it was just chaos
and like James getting up like it was a
little performative you know but I love
him yeah but he is really angry and I
guess you have to think about the fact
that like Raquel was his fiancee and Tom
was his friend and and Tom paid for
their engagement and right and I wish
they dived into that a little bit more
that is one of the great wonders of the
world to me like why the [__] did he pay
for that yeah also why isn't something
about her open yet because like on the
end of the season it felt like they
could open in a month well they said end
of May and that's now so we'll see but I
haven't been seeing like promotional
materials like where like wouldn't they
have opening day
like an event yeah you know what I mean
right let me check the Instagram like I
want them to open me too because there's
a lot of momentum people won't care
about this for that long yeah no and I
thought it was really smart of them to
start selling merch and I guess they put
that money into the business it's so
smart and then they didn't have to get
maybe investors
coming 2023
in the reunion they said May and they
haven't posted since March 6th that's a
wasted opportunity yeah especially since
the point of the shop was to be like a
low lift sort of thing right right
so they gotta get
they got to get open
um I thought really I wouldn't say
anyone came off super well or super good
I think Schwartz came off really bad but
this is kind of like the
what's I'm always looking for Reckoning
thank you the Reckoning like years in
the making for Tom Schwartz and like I'm
honestly here for it yeah maybe even
more so than I'm here for the Tom
Sandoval Reckoning like I literally hate
Tom Schwartz right because there's
nothing ambiguous about this Tom
Sandoval Reckoning like it's bad is bad
you know but with Schwartz it's like now
I'm seeing everything differently
and
it's nice to watch him get his his just
come up and so I thought he made a good
comparison like the whole season I'm
like schwarzen Markel making out is so
wrong like so bad whatever but then when
he explained the situation like if Katie
had done it like they're in the same
house
uh Schwartz wants the divorce blah blah
and then Katie goes and makes out with
Peter like nobody would care no but I
think that's because Peter is really not
in the group like if he went out if she
went out and made out with the thing is
there's no other single guys like to
compare James like for example it would
be a big deal yeah that's true it's
because Peter was not inaccurate Peter
is not Raquel Raquel is a main character
on the show yeah
okay
but I did think he did provide color
like he really was in a sense
I hate to use this word but like a
little bit of the victim in the divorce
I didn't realize like that his brother
still had cancer like he was just he was
going through a lot yeah and then he got
divorced and we know he didn't want the
divorce we want we know Katie did so
like yes he was like the injured party
here but he still agreed to this
agreement nope and he and he broke the
agreement so wrong is wrong and just for
a kiss like for right literally with
some Harlot who was [__] your best
friend right
so honestly like it was exciting and it
was you know funny at times but I don't
feel like we made really any major
progress in the conversations because
everybody was just like wilding out yeah
it was a little frustrating it was
hopefully next week things could come
down more Sheena breaks down next week
apparently there's a big bombshell that
comes out really and I don't know what
it is a lot of people were speculating
that Raquel is pregnant
um you don't think that's true a lot of
people that you know there were those
rumors about Brock
and Raquel I don't think that's it I
don't know what it is I don't know if
the bombshell is about China I don't
know if the bombshell is about who the
other person that Tom admitted to
cheating with I don't know and I don't
know if it comes out in part two or
three but apparently there's a big
bombshell
I don't think the bombshell is what's
going to make Sheena cry though I think
that Sheena might be going through
something in her personal life outside
of all of this and it's just a different
conversation that's right maybe some
fertility related or yeah I don't know
hmm I don't know either but there is a
big bombshell yeah and somehow Sheen is
a partner Sheena and Lala bought houses
in Palm Springs oh wait that was an
interesting conversation about China
Lala Katie and Katie was 100 right like
if this roles were reversed and Katie
was friends with someone that Lala
wasn't getting along with how Lala would
you know be at a hundred being like
you're dead to me and so that's all
Katie said I thought Katie was right and
it's true like Katie and Sheena have
legitimate beef like Sheena championed
this girl making out with her ex-husband
and like lala is the type of person that
demands like 100 loyalty from all of her
friends so like Katie's allowed to be a
little [__] miffed about it no but
then at that point I kind of like did
feel bad for Sheena in that moment
because like I felt like lala was like
minimizing their friendship to explain
to Katie she was like I mean it's really
just because of the kids and it's like
okay well like we're also friends like
and it's like and it's not they
literally want to all live together no I
know and that's fine but like she was
really minimizing the friendship just to
like make Katie feel better and like
sheena's just sitting there being like
yeah I felt bad for her yeah but like
Sheena needs to make it right with Katie
and she has to like go through the
emotions of of accepting like what she
did was wrong like she was completely
wrong in that situation yeah and I don't
think Katie's like easily forgiving
people at this point but I do think her
and Sheena like need to make it right
yeah I don't think she's easily
forgiving people especially people who
like what is there to salvage between
her and Sheena they literally have not
been able to get along for 10 years like
yeah maybe they're just not meant to be
friends no that's true that's true some
people like just don't get along and
that's fine it's because everyone's so
different like personality by the way
the Joe stuff was weird
so I didn't realize like her and Tom
like were [__] at some point shorts
yes and then they went on like a trip
with Raquel and Joe like that's so weird
yeah
no there was like the more we unpack and
that's why I wish everyone had just
[__] slowed down the more we unpack
like the more guilty Tom Schwartz and
Tom Sandoval are like it's not just the
affair like it was very layered and if
everybody just calmed down we would
really see
all the [__] that they did to hide this
yeah and all the weird things they did
yeah like why wasn't Ariana invited on
that trip it was before they found out
about the affair and it's Joe Sandoval
Schwartz and Raquel I feel like I read
somewhere about that trip that it was
like the toms went on a trip Schwartz
invited Joe
and Joe came and brought Raquel R Kelly
crash a trip and then it turns into like
this double date no and the fact that
like now we're getting the timeline like
a glamping like Schwartz and Sandy had
known and they had already [__]
um weird like I just I need to re-watch
everything now you know yeah like when
it gives her that big a hug and when
Santa when Schwartz is like I know
Raquel's type taken
layered yeah
these people were so brave like yeah and
the fact that like what Ali saw at the
Abbey was the night and was exactly what
everyone was scared it might be
and I was like how were they dancing and
it was the night they started but like
were they grinding they must have been
like so I I wish you would describe the
type of dance or was it like maybe Ollie
will come out and explain right were
they doing the Cha-Cha yeah or sometimes
like you dance it's like you know
pointing yeah you can dance with another
person
but are you like grinding legs between
legs you know yeah yeah it must have
been nefarious but why didn't she say so
why didn't you say they were grinding at
the Abbey I don't know if people say
grinding anymore that's why it's
important yeah of course I think Ali
does come out at some point right I
can't believe this case wide open I also
don't see Tom Sandoval as a grinder I do
see him as more of like a jumping dancer
no I see him as like kind of like sexy
slow dancing like old couples at
weddings who like really like still get
it on you know and after the kids go to
bed they're just like like their hips
are like touching and they're like
swaying that's what I see him as
you know I think he would describe
himself as like an old soul I don't know
I kind of see him as like jumping around
pointing like not really well yeah when
he goes to Coachella not really
connecting yeah
but him and Raquel have a deep
connection so probably yeah
so I can't wait for next week I'm just
loving this journey it was so exciting
you know eight o'clock watching with
commercials like it was very exciting I
know it is sad not to have a Watch What
Happens live after today what the [__]
wait that was we've never done Watch
What Happens live after reunions before
like they don't have cast members on to
talk about the reunion because like
we're talking
oh but I feel like they've been
capitalizing on every inch of this yeah
they could have even had like two lay
people on to talk about the reunion not
even cast members I was like ready and
then it was summer House Martha's
Vineyard and I'm like oh cool where's
Andy yeah hmm
yeah so that's our job that's a recap
thank you so much for sitting always the
last episode of the week
uh we'll miss you I hope everyone has a
great holiday weekend stay safe have fun
eat a lot eat a little barbecue have a
hot dog yum yum yum thank you guys so
much for listening to the toaster Monday
Morning Show retail the fast five
stories didn't each and every Monday
Friday on YouTube so watching this on
YouTube please subscribing give this
video thumbs up Amazon
[Music]
holiday weekend we love you and we'll
see you on Tuesday love you bye